Newton's third law tells us that to
every action there's always an equal and
opposite reaction when I'm shooting the
ball I am clearly applying force to it
where is the equal and opposite reaction
that's an excellent question LeBron so
as you mentioned if someone's shooting a
ball they're clearly applying a force to
that ball and let me see if I can draw
that for so let's say that this is the
force that your hand is applying on the
ball and this force is what accelerates
the ball upwards and towards the basket
so force force applied by hand applied
by hand on the ball on the ball so where
is this equal and opposite force that
Newton's third law tells us about well
that's going to be the force that the
ball is applying to your hand and so
I'll draw it the force right here I can
draw it anywhere on the hand but I'll
draw it here just you see it's going in
the exact opposite direction it's going
in the exact opposite direction and it
has an equal magnitude so it's an equal
but opposite force opposite is the
direction so just like that so that is
the force that is the force force
applied by the ball applied by the ball
on your hand on your hand but then you
might say wait this doesn't make a lot
of sense the ball is clearly getting
accelerated in that direction but my
hand isn't accelerating backwards and in
kind of that opposite direction and the
reason why your hand isn't accelerating
backwards isn't just flopping backwards
because of this force of the ball
applying to the hand the reason is is
because your hand or your fingers have
other forces acting on it that
counteract this force so for example the
reason why your fingers in your hand
don't flop backwards don't accelerate
backwards because of this force is
because you have muscles in your forearm
you have muscles in your forearm Rock
roughly right around there that are
pulling that are pulling on your fingers
and on your hand and are counteracting
this force so they are counteracting
that first one they say okay I get fair
enough I see why my fingers aren't
flopping back and what my hand isn't
flopping back it's because of these
muscles right over here but why is it my
entire forearm being pushed or
accelerated back by this force applied
by the ball on my hand
and the reason is is that you have other
muscles you have other muscles in the
back of your upper arm in particular
your triceps that are keeping that are
keeping that are tugging that are
tugging on your forearm that are tugging
on your forearm its contracting they're
contracting that more than offset any
net force on your forearm that maybe
want to make it go that way it's pulling
on your forearm and in fact that's
what's contracting and allow your
forearm to go in actually that direction
and we can keep going I mean the the fun
or the complicated thing about Newton's
third law is well if every force has an
equal and opposite force well every one
of these we have have an equal opposite
force and we can keep going on is okay
there's an equal and opposite force of
the the tricep tugging on the forearm
well that's the forearm clicking on the
tricep but why does it the tricep move
well the tricep is attached to other
parts of your body and we could keep
going on and on and on but just to focus
on the question your hand is definitely
applying a force to the ball but the
equal and opposite force is the force
that the ball is applying to the hand
but we actually even though we said that
your hand isn't flopping back because
it's being balanced you actually can
sense this force and the reason why you
do sense this force is you actually do
have the ball compressing against your
against the palm of your hand if it
didn't do that you wouldn't even feel
the ball so that gives you at least a
sensory clue of Newton's third law it's
if news third law wasn't true you
wouldn't even feel the ball you wouldn't
even have the ball compress against the
skin of your palm